I'm in DC I'm talking to a bunch of
these folks and I said so let me ask you
a question what's the biggest thing
you're concerned about the room is about
70 percent uh women you hear ladies
saying grocery shopping has gone up I
said I said what do you mean by it yep a
milk today 5 29 to buy milk and it was
three dollars last year I said what do
you mean milk has gone up from whatever
it was three bucks to 529 the first
thing they talked about was milk I mean
you have to these are mothers these are
parents these are sitting there saying
what they got to be doing with it and by
the way when people start spending a
little bit more on credit card what is
it saying to you it's saying uh they
kind of need it it's emergency a lot of
people use their credit cards as a
source of emergency fund although
emergency funds should be an emergency
fund not a credit card so people are
leaning towards credit cards so it's
going to be interesting what happens
next quarter because whether it's
trending towards uh this happening more